-Welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show"!
Thank you very much, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, guys, it was another
big day in Washington,
as House Democrats
formally introduced
the resolution to impeach
President Trump.
And if you're watching,
no, this is not a repeat.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, Trump is being
impeached again.
Right now, everyone in America
is having déjà coup.
[ Laughter ]
This morning, Trump was charged
with "incitement
of insurrection."
You know you messed up
when you're charged with the
title of a '90s Star Trek movie.
[ Laughter ]
Seriously, it's never good
when your crowds rise
to the level of Klingon.
It's looking like
one more impeachment for Trump.
Trump gets impeached the way
most people get vaccinated --
in two doses.
Some people say impeaching Trump
will divide the country.
Really? How much more divided
can the country get?
We're currently in a state
of Monopoly game
after Thanksgiving.
That's where we are.
Meanwhile, some of Trump's
most loyal defenders are saying
we shouldn't kick him
while he's down.
Even "The Karate Kid" is going,
"Eh, this one time
feels okay, I think.
Sweep the leg, sweep the leg."
Well, if you think Trump's upset
about getting impeached,
imagine how he felt the other
day when Twitter announced
that they're permanently
suspending his account.
A lifetime ban.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Trump's basically the Pete Rose
of social media.
[ Laughter ]
Right now, Trump's phone
is stuffed into a pile of rice
after being drenched with tears.
[ Laughter ]
The good news is
now Twitter can go back
to what it used to be for --
judging celebrities
at award shows.
In addition to Twitter, Trump
has been banned or restricted
from Apple, Facebook,
Instagram, Snapchat,
Google, Amazon,
Pinterest, TikTok...
[ Inhales deeply ]
...YouTube, Reddit, Twitch,
Stripe, Discord, and Shopify.
-Aw.
[ Laughter ]
-Trump started this year
thinking he should
be on Mount Rushmore.
Now can't even get on Instagram.
Seriously, in one weekend,
Trump's phone became
a $2,000 flashlight.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Yep, now Trump can't tweet,
snap, post, or stream.
It's gotten so bad,
he can't even sell
embroidered pillows on Etsy.
-Aw.
-Hmm.
-Of course now we're going
to have to settle
with him holding
50 press conferences a day
and yelling 280 characters
at a time.
Ah, it's 2:00 a.m. Time
for another press conference.
Things have gotten so bad
for Trump that PGA announced
that they will no longer
hold the 2022 PGA Championship
at Trump National Golf Club
in Bedminster, New Jersey.
[ Applause ]
No more Twitter, no more PGA.
If Diet Coke comes out
against Trump,
he's going to lose his mind.
Again.
Let's change gears here.
Oh, this was fun.
Yesterday, Nickelodeon
aired its first-ever
kid-friendly broadcast
of an NFL playoff game.
Check out what it looked like.
-Now plunging forward.
End zone and touchdown.
-Hey, there's the slime!
[ Imitating air horn ]
-And now Wil Lutz will come on
for the extra point.
And he kicks it
right through Spongebob.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. That actually
looked normal to me.
Then again, I watch every game
after dropping
an insane amount of acid.
[ Laughter ]
"Uh, that was right through
Spongebob there.
Congratulations."
[ Laughter ]
It was great. The slime cannons?
-Yeah.
-It was awesome.
A lot of people enjoyed
seeing the game like this.
I mean, it was way better
than the time
they had the Rugrats
host a UFC fight.
[ Laughter ]
That just didn't work.
Some entertainment news --
HBO announced
that they are rebooting
"Sex and the City."
Yeah.
[ Applause ]
Even crazier, there's also
going to be a version
that airs on Nickelodeon.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, everyone is back,
except Kim Cattrall won't
reprise her role as Samantha.
It's like "The Avengers"
rebooting, but Thor is like,
"You won't be seeing
this hammer."
[ Laughter ]
[ Cymbals tapping ]
Yep, 17 years
after the final episode,
"Sex and the City" coming back.
They already released
an episode,
and the first 20 minutes
is Mr. Big waiting
for his pill to kick in.
[ Laughter, groaning ]
And finally I saw
that Dwayne "The Rock" Johnson
is launching a healthy
energy drink called ZOA.
You can tell the drink is good.
Nancy Pelosi just chugged one,
crushed the can on her forehead,
and said,
"Let's impeach this Jimbroni."
Hi, everyone!
Thank you very much.
it is Monday.
We're excited to be back,
and we got a fantastic week
of shows ahead.
Nicole Kidman will be here!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Amazing.
Did you see "The Undoing"?
-Yeah, I did.
-She crushed it, man.
Anthony Mackie will be here.
Oh, I love Anthony Mackie.
Plus, Anne Hathaway,
Angela Bassett, Lilly Singh.
Oh, stay up late tonight.
Lilly Singh is premiering
tonight after Seth.
So it goes me, Seth, then Lilly.
But it premieres tonight.
We love you, Lilly Singh.
Check out Lilly tonight.
But first, we have a great show
for you tonight.
She stars in the movie
"On the Rocks" on Apple TV Plus.
Rashida Jones is here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Plus, from the film
"The King of Staten Island"
and "The Mandalorian,"
Bill Burr is here.
God.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That dude is next-level funny.
-Yeah, man.
-He's on a different world, man.
He's just -- Gosh,
I just love that guy so much.
And we got great music
from Old Dominion!